it is remarkably an incredibly important
concept that is at the heart of our
theories of how the universe and how
matter behaves and yet we don't
understand it you know i actually teach
this to the first year undergraduates
and what i tell them is that if they
think they've understood it then they
probably haven't we can't measure it
we can't observe it and that's not
because our instruments aren't good
enough it's just fundamentally built
into the theory we cannot see a wave
function that's a cool symbol it is a
curl symbol indeed so it looks like a
looks like a pitchfork
at the very microscopic scale the world
becomes very fuzzy um and so particles
that you know that we like to think of
electrons and protons that we sort of
like to think of as little billiard
balls
don't behave that way at all they don't
they no longer have a well-defined
position in space for example they kind
of spread out a bit and you can't say in
a very fundamental way exactly where a
particle is it could be here it could be
here it could be here and so the only
way you can actually express
that you know physically what's going on
is to associate a probability you say
well you know it's a high probability
that it's here and there's a low
probability that it's here but you can't
say for definite exactly where a
particle is
and the wave function is just really the
mathematical way of expressing that
probability of where the particle
actually is in space oh the wave
function is the version of quantum
mechanics
invented by owen schroedinger and it's
a complex quantity which i don't want to
go into but actually the wave function
is related to the probability of finding
a particle somewhere
but the more complicated thing was
schroedinger's life
in 1938 i think he was invited to oxford
by lindemann and traveled there with his
wife and his girlfriend and set up a
menage menage a trois two women and him
living together in the same household
and when lindemann and others found out
about it in oxford he uh was invited to
leave and and found himself uh just
before the outbreak of the second world
war in germany he was rescued there by
the irish who spirited him out to dublin
and he spent the war there
with his wife and he managed to get
another mistress an irish girl pregnant
and
he his wife and this irish girl brought
up the baby themselves so he had a very
very complicated life which was probably
typical of quite a lot of german
scientists from berlin at the time
berlin in the 30s being quite a racy
place it's
our quantum theory has at its core and
wave function has it as a core the idea
of an imaginary number the idea of the
square root of minus one
and so we are using it seems absolutely
mad to somebody who isn't a
mathematician or a physicist it seems
bizarre and it is mad in some respects
when you think about it that we're using
imaginary numbers square root of minus
one something that cannot exist in the
real world to describe reality and
that's that that's absolutely remarkable
and so we can certainly on a computer
plot out we can take molecules and we
can look maybe if you want to come over
here
we can plot out and this is
actually some work from collaborators in
in cork in something called the tyndall
institute and i have to thank somebody
called jacob baron for this but what you
can see here is is a molecule in this
case it's c60 c60 is a wonderfully
symmetric molecule it's like a um
basically a molecular football and we
can take that map and we can convert
that mathematically into a map that then
tells us what the probability of finding
an electron is what do those blobs
represent and so those blobs represent
the wave function itself represent well
here the wave function positive here the
wave function's negative here's how the
wave function spreads out across the
molecule and so for example there's a
classic experiment in physics called the
the young slit experiment the double
slit experiment which you can do with
particles you can do with particles like
electrons and basically you have a beam
of electrons firing along and a pair of
little slits and the electrons go
through
and very fundamentally because the
electron's position is not defined you
can't say which slit it go through it
goes through both this is one particle
going through two holes at the same time
particles really aren't supposed to
behave that way or at least on the
macroscopic scale are things that we're
used to dealing with and that's why the
concepts are so incredibly difficult to
explain because you have to accept that
at some very fundamental level that's
the way the universe works
one thing you might do if you were doing
this double slit experiment with a
particle going through and say okay so
why don't i just set up some very clever
little gizmo which will actually measure
whether or not a particle goes through
one slit or the other and then i can
actually say which slit the particle
goes through
and the amazing thing is whatever thing
you set up to detect which slit the
particle's actually gone through you can
detect it but then suddenly all the
quantum mechanical effects go away that
suddenly the particle yes you can detect
it and it only ever when you actually
make the measurement it only ever goes
through one slit
but suddenly all the quantum mechanical
effects go away and that's this thing of
collapsing the wave function when you
make a measurement you go from a
probabilistic thing well either the
particles hear all the particles here to
saying on this occasion the particle is
definitely here doesn't that mean you
just solve the puzzle what other quantum
mechanical effects have gone away so
let's go back to this twin slit thing
again if you don't make that measurement
of actually saying which slip did the
electron go through because the electron
then goes through first and because it's
behaving like a wave when it comes out
the other side the two waves interfere
with one another and so you actually see
interference effects between the two
waves you see basically you see fringes
if you ever do if you have a tank of
water and you just make ripples in it
and you'll see that the waves travel
through each other but as they're
traveling through each other they
interfere and in some places you get big
waves in other places you get no waves
at all and you can do exactly the same
thing with this double slit experiment
you can get the the electrons to
interfere with each other and produce
these wave patterns that you'd you see
as you see in in
in tanks of water
but the amazing thing is that you can do
it one electron at a time so one
electron can interfere with itself as
long as you don't do this thing of
collapsing the wave function so if you
leave it as a wave function you can
actually get one electron to interfere
with itself and so that really is a
fundamentally associated with the wave
function um and that gives you a really
in sense that the wave function in some
sense is the real particle that's what's
really going on i think quantum
mechanics is so totally
counter-intuitive
that it seems stupid to everybody it
looks at first sight as though it can't
be right the problem with it is okay so
that's fine i can explain it and they'll
nod and as you've been nodding and
they're all you know they're happy with
the explanation
but then the way physics works is so you
have problems you know you have to solve
some problems we set them an exam
question or they've got some physics
experiment they're doing they're trying
to understand or whatever
and you get to the end of an experiment
or you get to the end of an exam
question
the first thing you should do is look at
the answer and think does that make
sense because almost always in physics
if you've got an answer that sort of
makes no sense at all to you you've
probably done something wrong and you
need to look back up the calculation or
play with your apparatus some more to
try and find out where you might have
made a mistake
the terrible thing about quantum
mechanics is it because it predicts such
completely counter-intuitive things you
know you can have particles in two
places at once you can actually have
particles tunneling through solid walls
and so on
do you end up with a result at the end
that you think that can't be right and
bizarrely in quantum mechanics if you
get to an answer at the end that says
that can't be right then you probably
have got it right but that makes it very
hard for to really grasp it to really
understand the subject because you
always end up with these completely
counter intuitive answers at the end
why should you introduce this wave
function when
in the world we live in well with
everything is
large scale and cricket balls especially
for australia that swing around the
place or
classical objects such as a book that
can fall on your foot it doesn't really
matter whether you're using
any other language you're always going
to think of these as material objects
but when you get down to the tiny
they're very small
such as an electron or a neutrino you
have to describe it in terms of a wave
function because it is not pri
it's obeying a completely different set
of laws of motion and it's when you go
from the very small and you aggregate
these particles together that out of
that emerges the classical world in
which we live
so it's hidden from us
because we only see things on a large
scale
i certainly get b to see those huge
paintings by money
enormous things that cover a wall and as
you go close to it you can see it's all
blurry and fuzzy i mean that's it when
you go back from the picture you see the
garden on the water lilies
and and if you're up close you magnify
it closely it hasn't got the behavior of
being a classical picture it has the
impression of being broken up into
little dorbz here and there and and the
genius of money was to be able to have a
huge picture on the wall
enormous much bigger than the size of
one of these walls and to stand back
from it and see how he could go forwards
and paint a little door there and it
would add to part of the picture i can't
imagine how i can do that well in
quantum mechanics is a bit like that you
have to stand back from it
look at the whole picture and then
imagine
that you can put a little dorb somewhere
the quantum mechanical wave function
such that when you go back to the
realistic world you the world we live in
i mean the world we live in not the
realistic world the world we live in
then this little
quantum mechanical wave function could
add up to an atom inside a cricket ball
or an electron inside a cricket ball and
become the microscopic object we
normally see everyone loves quantum
mechanics it's probably in the first
year in the core physics that they do so
i teach two things in the core physics
to the first year which are special
relativity and quantum mechanics and i
have to say i have the best job in the
first year because it's the physics
everyone wants to learn about and
everyone goes uh about so you know it's
really fun to teach the students really
enjoy it and it's one of those things
you know if people have this idea that
students are kind of lazy and want to do
the easy stuff actually what they really
like is this stuff and it's hard
you